in breaking news
we've received reports of an explosion
somewhere north of the city we're still
waiting for the police to confirm
if there are any victims this story is
evolving rapidly
please bear with us this really loud
boom there was smoke
and emergency services have confirmed
that they've discovered a body buried in
the wreckage
we're still waiting for further
collapsed details news an explosion
rocked gotham city earlier
you're now able to confirm that
billionaire philanthropist bruce wayne
is
if you're watching this i'm dead
this is a cold black
this message was automatically triggered
when i destroyed the cave and everything
it contained
we both know it won't take long for
gotham's criminals to realize the batman
is gone
and you can't count on the gcpd haven't
trusted us since
jim died gotham will need its protectors
more than ever
[Music]
i'm leaving you the belfry as base of
operations
some of the technology is outdated but
it has the gear you need and all of my
files
you've always had my back when i needed
you i know you'll keep gotham safe
good luck and goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no one talks about them
[Music]
not a whisper word is said
for if you try to crush them
then the town
strikes you dead
you